This is the Chris Abraham Show.
Hey, this is Chris Abraham, The
Chris Abraham Show season five
episode 41.
And I'm doing walkies.
And because yesterday was so
intense and and crazy and about
Stephanie, that I thought I
would make it a little bit more
chillax.
And more general.
I'm watching a little bit of
this TV show season nine of
Alone.
It's on Netflix cuz I don't have
The History Channel.
It's pretty awesome.
And there was one guy there
named Jacques, I think Jacques
and he bailed after like two or
three days.
Cuz he was he really.
He wondered what he was
challenging himself for when
his.
His girlfriend and his dog made
his life happy every day.
And I hated to say, I mean it
was sweet, right?
It was sweet.
But like, here are my thoughts.
My thoughts are as follows.
Firstly there, it's a
competition, so it's not like he
just went out to challenge
himself in the Labrador forest.
With no goal in mind, his goal
was to win $500,000 which could
really help him, his family and
all the therapy he needs based
on how terrible is growing up
was.
So also 100 to 120 days is
nothing in the in.
Mind you, Jacques is 23/22/23,
so.
It's very interesting, right?
It's a little, very interesting
in a world of perspective.
Because I have.
What are you doing?
Oh, OK.
Sorry.
Anyway, I was just happen to be
in like the area where this guy
was trying to park and so very
funny, thought I was being
stalked.
So yeah, it was very sweet.
And I'm hoping that he also felt
really bad about killing a
squirrel, and he said that if he
weren't a group, he'd feel
better about it.
And whatever, 23, right?
I mean, he might not ever get an
opportunity like this again.
And I hope see my skeptical
world of like this reveals
something about me, right?
It revealed that the gift that I
would have of leaving after two
or three days because I missed
my dog and my girlfriend so much
and went home to them.
Would not be enough of a love
bomb and a show of like
selflessness and devotion to my
small little family as being a
pussy and like potentially
losing our young family half
$1,000,000, right?
So it's it's similar to the way
I feel about kids who go home on
camp.
Because they miss their mommy
too much, right?
Like I haven't, even though he
touched my heartstrings.
And I totally appreciate the
fact since I grew up with two
alcoholic parents in a very kind
of bullying world As a as a
Howley kid in Hawaii, I still
feel like, you know, you got to
man up and and and you got to
do.
You got to complete the mission,
right?
So on one hand, I find it like
my empathetic, like I've been
pursuing empathy this year, both
for myself and for others.
And I've also been pursuing
like, like, like rigorous
kindness both to myself and to
others and forgiveness for
myself and others like rigorous,
Like all I think about is that
and that, Chris.
Really love the fact that this
young man realized he has
everything he wanted, and ever
since he's been with his
girlfriend and his dog, he
hasn't.
That's when his good memories
began.
Now, if this guy were a soldier,
he wouldn't be able to just quit
three days in right on
deployment.
He might be able to wash out if
you were going out for something
like buds or boot camp or
whatever, but and I know this is
just TV and it's not real life
and so forth, but on one hand, I
feel such compassion for him
that he knew that what he had
right in front of him is what he
wanted and needed more than
anything, and that this
challenge that he was putting
himself through.
The fact that the money never
came up made me believe that he
never believed he would win the
money or win.
It's not just a challenge like,
you know, my business partner
Mark or someone like Raman or or
Andrew.
My buddies would like just go
off into the wilderness like
adventure bike camping,
disappear forever and for the
challenge.
There was no half $1,000,000 at
the end of it, right?
So and then like the other side
of me is like will she ever
perceive him as?
Will she start to see the
relationship as something he
will pull the cord on?
Will she now feel?
Will she look at his behavior
since he's only 23?
pulling the ripcord?
Will she perceive that as a
character flaw which is going to
doom the relationship because
she'll never be able to respect
him or fully trust him again?
Or did she miss him so much and
that their family is so insular?
That she just wants them home so
that they can start making
beautiful Jacques babies.
Like, old Chris is like fucking
loser pussy freak.
And new Chris is like, oh man, I
really loved being a universe of
two.
Like, there were times when I
was with Stephanie, Or when I
was with Liz, or when I was with
Michelle, or when I was with
Georgina.
Like, even Georgina, we never
lived together.
Like, even with Wendy, right?
Like there were times when I'm
like if I can extrapolate on
this moment vis A vis Groundhog
Day, if I could live this day ad
nauseam into immortality, not
just for the remaining 50-60
years at the time.
I would do it right.
Wake up in bed together, take a
shower, have some coffee, maybe
a little breakfast.
Have a little kiss, Get dressed,
Go out to into the world.
Meet up later.
Maybe have a drink, maybe have
some dinner, Maybe order in.
Maybe watch some dumb TV.
Maybe go on a picnic.
Maybe visit a new restaurant.
Maybe go on a run in the morning
or go on the run in the evening.
Maybe go to a gym together with
Betsy.
A lot of those days were
perfect.
Like wake up in the morning,
make some coffee, make some
breakfast.
Go off to work, come back home,
take trips to Paris, take trips
to Florida, Miami.
You know, one of the great
experiences was like the perfect
days included days where we're
living together in in South
Arlington, in in Pentagon City.
Like, even going to ballet bar
going, no, not ballet bar, going
to biker bar and going into DC
and taking spin classes
together, right?
Like if I had a partner, who'd
want to take spin classes with
me, like, you know, 3-4 times a
week for the rest of my life,
that would be smashing.
If I had a partner that would
like to go and encourage me.
To go to park run on Saturday
and go with me like that would
be spectacular.
So I can't diss him like when I
was 23.
Would I want to spend 100 days
away from Stephanie?
Like, I don't know.
I don't know.
Probably not at least at 1st
until I became an idiot.
So.
So, like, there's the conundrum,
right?
There's the conundrum of suck it
up, Buttercup.
Cowboy up half a million.
Like if you won that money, you
know the IT would makes things
so much easier for that
relationship, right?
So, and for the future, and for
having children.
And for buying a house.
And for buying a car.
And for.
Getting outfitted and for, you
know, putting together a
retirement plan or putting money
aside for the future baby to
have college money, You know,
things like that.
And definitely therapy for what
you perceived as a terrible
childhood.
You don't even have to ever
think of yourself having a
terrible childhood for therapy
to be a good idea for a man.
But if you if if your entire
narrative is what is shitty
childhood you have and how
fucking shitty your parents are
and were like, that's a
signifier that maybe you need a
little bit of therapy or you
need to go to Al Anon.
I recommend for Jacques I
recommend Jacques go to Al Anon.
That is the that is a 12 step
program for.
Children of Alcoholics, adult
children of Alcoholics, people
who love Alcoholics, partners of
Alcoholics and all that kind of
stuff that teaches you things
like, you know, how to deal with
codependency and how to deal
with issues of independence.
And and honestly, if you had
gone to Al Anon or therapy
before this challenge, you would
realize.
That being away for 120 days
with the opportunity to win a
half $1,000,000 is the healthy
choice.
It's the healthy choice.
And that being so afraid that
your your relationship is not
going to suffer those hundred
2000 thirty days.
The fear that your relationship
is so fragile that everything
will come apart is really the
kind of.
Of of damaged heart and damaged
soul and general sadness that
needs surely, surely needs to be
addressed and will be addressed
and can be addressed by Al Anon
and ality and and in therapy and
learning how not to be
codependent and learning how to
stand on your own 2 feet.
And learning not to put the
weight of the world of all of
your happiness.
On the weight of a dog and a
petite blonde woman.
So I'm speaking from experience.
I'm speaking from experience,
put a lot of pressure on my
girlfriends over the years, a
lot of expectation and all that
fun stuff.
So with that being said, I am
within highball range of
Starbucks coffee and they have a
an espresso and some water for
me.
And I am listening to an
interview with Greg Gutfeld on a
podcast, and I think it's very
enjoyable.
I really like that show.
But I refuse to pay for.
I refuse to pay for cable or you
know, I refuse to pay like, you
know, YouTube TV or Hulu TV or.
Any of those other services that
are like $75 plus in order to
get that kind of that kind of
real time kind of stuff?
Anyway, talk to you soon.
Thanks for walking me to
Starbucks and I love you.
Aloha.
This was Chris Abraham season
five episode 41, and I'll see
you the next time.
Ciao.
Thank you for listening to The
Chris Abraham Show.
Make sure you subscribe so you
don't miss any future episodes.
Until next time.